what's that believed nation happy
weekend I am joined by Nina and Timo and
we even have what's going Nina just got
a new job so I cut up Alex we just got a
new job Nina got any job not me I love
my job I have a great job it's the best
job I have the best and worst boss in
the world I need to go to the job so we
celebrate am I going to Montreal
you've never been no first time going
I've been as on spin yes has been first
time going
teemo's first time out of the province
we are bringing a couple of snacks with
us Cheetos and caramel popcorn and I got
some chocolate covered raisins tucked
into my arm we're gonna go pick up
Hayden and then do the six hour drive to
Montreal and we're gonna take you with
us on our adventure
where are my snacks I want to go to
Montreal Alex you're staying here yeah
he has lives to change yeah I mean I'm
happy I'm happy I love that CA there's
spot for our school
Goudas you ready to go yeah where we
going thank you
we're gonna leave when yeah high five
boom I did bring the dryin bin what else
yeah what else do you want to see case
okay let's go
so we're about to spend six six and a
half hours in the car with an
eight-year-old yeah he's gonna be a
great boy the whole time he's just gonna
pass out maybe I read us some stories
make some quality content to help people
believe in themselves right yeah
okay let's go
nice right - caramel fat for me ready to
kill a brutal a latte yeah first sip
that is good Nina wants the warm drink
always but I'll take a Frappuccino any
day
even though should be snow here still go
cold
ok let's go find Hayden Nina and get our
pizza if I had a piece place I would
have believed shrooms as a topping
option it'd be the best mushrooms ever
she won't look sad
he won't you okay you okay mister you
look sad to you believe nation loves you
Timo what any neranenah doing though
they're playing field runners hey that's
pretty good at this game
okay that's the strategy you got it down
I feel like Tino should be playing too
and I was watching what are we eating
what did you order
just pepperoni cheese all right
something special like believe shrooms
no you guys didn't you didn't get that
in you didn't like that all right
people have to like the bleachers look
at the pizza
oh ho it's all mine it's all mine
all right taking a quick pit stop throw
away some garbage have a bathroom break
hit up the washroom we are about another
two and a half hours out having some fun
in the car and we're gonna get inside
it's getting cold how's the ride so far
guys good two and a half then we're more
than halfway there pretty good hey yeah
let's go we'll go inside did you bring a
dog inside Nina yeah well pretty sure
pretty sure there's a sign Nina what is
that sign right there yeah what does
that mean that Nina likes to break the
rules that's why I married her we love
you Nina you had enough junk in the car
mister no no no no no no we're going
back okay let's go hello
take my hand we'll make it I swear woah
livin on a prayer
funky purple bridge
that's totally a bridge but there's
stuff happening on it
likes going all over it
that's crazy what a crazy bridge Wow
welcome to Montreal I like it
we have arrived at our Airbnb this guy
is up way past his bedtime and he's very
cold so let's get him inside
what's your jacket let's get him in
how do you feel now warmer Hayden has
his jacket on Timo has his jacket on and
we're gonna go inside and get this guy
to bed and gets his own queen-size bed
and the TV is bigger than him the TV at
the TV is bigger than you mister
I don't know I think maybe the couch
outside instead what do you think huh
now we've lost him we've lost them yeah
you know what the good news is we got a
giant bed and our TVs bigger ha ha ha
you need to get ready for bed it's past
your bedtime mister we already saw your
room we got our dining room here I'm
gonna set it up in the kitchen nice and
Oh sir Hayden so hating on the
queen-size bed it's an okay size TV now
it's pretty big you like your bed high
five boom oh with the foot yeah with the
hand now with the hand now at the hand
hand okay bedtime mister
okay let's get ready ready ready ready
ready ready brush your teeth okay any
last words for the camera
goodbye goodnight first thing I have to
do you guys know it when I travel gotta
turn on the TV and find CNN that
officially means am on vacation
come on hon see ya then see ya then see
ya then there's another room really
there's another room oh yeah this is
Hayden's room no TV nice and small no
where you going you know what this could
be tea Meserve fuel gets his own room
that was an extra room okay guys most
important let's let's give our
priorities priorities guys priorities
see you an end what what what I'm
working on something very important oh
my gosh what do you need what do you
need what what what's in here what you
have a closet that's what you want
that's how you want to show me oh my
gosh okay go to bed mister we got I got
very important things to do here like
fine CNN okay that's not CNN this is
some kids thing this is very distressing
guys what am I looking for here yeah but
what do I show in the settings no info
no where's like the channel listings
channel listings
oh I'm thinking I see different ones now
I see different ones now ha I saw
something I don't know what it was but I
saw something no I didn't solve anything
I think it's the exact same thing very
sad
wow that's not the solution oh wow
what is this Hayden's gonna like this
show for sure look at him Oh guys it's
very sad it's a sad day when you travel
and there's no CNN but we'll have to
make do I believe okay it is what one no
its past one time is it oh no it's one
Harry it's 1:30 this is later than we
normally stay up I know we what do we do
I just did we watched some TV I did some
work I mean I was booking some travel
for us Nick the next job and uh we got
set up yeah so we're gonna hit the bed
wake up tomorrow I have a full date
Montreal that's what surprises play
society faces what
oh yeah what what did you planned for
tomorrow
that's a price is different you know
well you don't know then no right there
it's a surprise
all right have a good night
and we'll see you tomorrow